[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
questions people had for the wdc works
um yes thank you um i think they're
playing with that's a really good report
i found that really
helpful and targeted at you know
specific works and
the recommendations so thanks for that
um i was just interested
in the one on page seven of our notes
um the two um notifications of
significant
immunity landscapes and outstanding
natural landscapes i think that's really
good i'm really pleased to say that
they're actually rivers being recognized
by
those two um not just because the
reports were there but from the school
but
it was a bit of bias there but uh really
pleased to see them
um what about the the red crunches what
are the provisions the draft provisions
that apply it i'm obviously interested
in the biodiversity but
in the landscape um generally you know
how are they going to be how are these
values going to be protected
have you are they available or are they
still um
in sort of confidential till the plans
drafted um yeah i believe these dogs are
confidential that something that the
planning team is still working on
um they are going to be uh having
um consulting weather with a group of
experts to
develop sort of things around the
vegetation clearance roles
um sort of i think over the next month
or so
yeah so it's definitely it's on our
radar
high natural character but what gives it
that natural character is lots of water
lots of clean water um not just the
vegetation obviously but and got to
recognize that you know biodiversity
contributes to that natural character so
can you see that protect it too thank
you
thanks guys i've got one pop quiz for
you on the courtney
um and your spawning work
so there was some research work done
a wee while ago wasn't i read somewhere
on spawning sites in the area
and in in our district so that had been
identified
upstream of the courtney as a as a
specific site that
could be enhanced
yes so the quality of ecology report by
mark taylor
and his crew did identify the
courtney the macintosh strain
and taraki stream as the particular
sites there were recommendations in that
report which i
followed for the selection of thing in
the spring enhancement program
so possibly andrew i'm not sure about
the floodgate
at the end of the courtney not that
you're going to replace the whole thing
but
does that need some sort of fish passage
option to improve that facility sorry
uh the short answer on the on the
courtney um
string floodgates under different names
is that we'd historically had one of
these
lever systems for opening the floodgates
longer
um to make them more passable for the
fish
back near the beginning of the year two
of the two of the floodgate flaps were
modified with with
modern more updated versions of those
and they're certainly our monitoring is
indicating that they are keeping the
floodgates open for
close on half an hour longer than if
those levers weren't there in place
and uh this certainly are some white
bait
um getting up through those floodgates
but it's been a very hard ask
them getting through those blood gates i
think by opening those tight gates and
leaving them a little bit uh
open longer we'll make it a little bit
easier for them and i
and therefore we're hoping a higher
proportion of the white bait arriving
though floodgates will get through
we also are looking at maybe modifying
all four because it's there's four
barrels to those floodgates and maybe
modifying the last romanian two as well
if we if we're seeing such good positive
steps from the ones at the moment
if you've got anything to update for me
and i know that marco is going to join
us shortly
um i suppose it was a little bit of
light in the degree of um
i was actually looking for something
else in one of my files and uh
sort of reflected on some work that
we've done in the in the past if you
recall back
as well just for reference that we're
looking at these because you'll probably
recognize them but if we go back sort of
about four years that was our list of
priorities and things i mean
you know we'll have a copy of those at
some point but when you do reflect on
those there's actually quite a bit of
work has been done
when you look back over that time
and importantly some of the projects you
do start to really recognize
that basically it kind of boils down to
good things take time some of the work
around the
the cam the the silver stream etc
have um taken a good two to three years
to actually get in place but they are
in place now and marco is going to touch
on some of the silver stream work
shortly um next slide you'll recall that
we uh
we sort of had a map that clustered
these together um
and once that has evolved over time
essentially the projects that are
sitting in the zipper
and i'd suggest might start to bubble to
the top
when you start looking at action plans
um really are just versions of
it's outdated versions of things so
those uh
what i would say there is when you get
good strong direction from the zone
committee as to the projects that
you'd like us to look at certainly we
can uh
collectively we can make things happen
and obviously now we've got the
um the updated version out of the zipper
as far as um
the word program goes in the next one
yep
yeah that that's not for you to be able
to see but effectively there's i think
118 recommendations
56 of those on the ground actions which
obviously we're
working on but mark i'm just going to
cover off uh
effectively the last few highlights from
the last six months
yes i'm um i'm assuming everybody's had
a read of
uh of our six months report that we
compile uh actually i think
we turn that one off
it's been a challenging last uh six
months for a number of reasons
um so really it was about um how do we
how do we still provide some momentum
for for the team um and for my team um
and that you know it worked well um for
what we
were able to work will be in limited
capacity
so um i guess it's just identifying a
couple of
the key points um that i provided you
and just
putting in some some more detail around
that um so i've just
picked three of those points um just to
expand on a little bit
so the first one we'll touch on is
silverstream loop
and uh and as andrew mentioned
previously yes so it's a couple of
locations
um where there was an excess of 15 000
plants
put in put in the ground at a cost of
around 150 000
so certainly um no
you know no easy task and some really
good numbers there
so the two locations are um
between connecting basically between
silver stream
and um reserve in the regional park
and the second location is on giles road
which was used for grazing
up until recently and now if anyone gets
a chance to go down there but we've got
some photos i think on here
if you want to flip flick over the other
um murray thanks
yeah so that's an aerial view of the of
the area um on charles road
um
let's go to the next one
and that's what it looks like well what
it looked like on the ground so
i have quite a bit of work yeah it's
just to say if i
drive past it regularly and i must say
every time i drive past it's like
there's a heap of plants it's um
that's something that's around 9000
plants in there
so um yeah and there's still some more
to go on that particular area but
i was talking to sandra before and it's
you may recall
sandra just raises a bit of an issue um
it's probably a couple years ago now but
there was a lot of hemlock
in there so the name sorry i might
interrupt him
the lane transferred from doc to us and
then we've taken over the management of
it um to lead him there
sorry michael johnson um so yeah it
really
it's going to look really good in years
to come um there was a little bit bit of
delay but we've worked through that just
with the uh soil moisture conditions at
the time i don't think we're good enough
for us to be able to put plants in so we
we delayed that um but it's all beer
coming out coming out really well
now the the second point i'd like to
make we've already
touched on and that is the taranaki
stream floodgate
obviously something that's been in the
works for some time and we finally got
there
obviously there's still some fine tuning
to do
we've worked through the the actual um
the the flood capacity of it and
once that's obviously honed and finely
tuned then the fish
passage side will fall into place um but
just definitely worth
worth noting and and some and we have
seen some a notable dis
difference as well from what i
understand with water water levels so
um he's hoping that uh yeah we'll it's
really good
um step in the right direction yes carol
just wondered whether the fruit had had
another look to
determine that the fish passage gate is
open and
do we know who opened it
no and no i think
i think our recent discussion with fred
is that he hadn't opened it unless
somebody had opened it so a member of
the public has opened up
so is that something that's desirable or
undesirable
i think yeah i think we've got to
probably secure it so we can
we can monitor it appropriately rather
than have sort of interference going on
so we can reassure people here it
probably needs to be padlocked shut
rather than just having a
just a nut and bolt through it
well only that i've been in
correspondence with our river engineers
to check out this
lost touch of this conversation are we
talking the taranaki
which was just to say that um we do have
a floodgate inspection program it's
normally done just before rain it's more
about the functioning but they do clear
out the stuff
and they'll get somebody down there in
the next couple of days but it was also
just confirming what andrew
adrian said that it had been opened and
it wasn't supposed to be
okay um so yes so
basically um looking at what we know so
far in terms of what they were designed
to do they seem to be working well
uh and third point um is the immediate
steps funding so as you all know
um the allocated budget has all been
spent we'll put towards projects and and
obviously the criteria is
as such that we want to make sure that
the money is going to a good home
and we're going to get desirable
outcomes so the fact that we're able to
do that in that
in this period despite our um you know
challenges and
people working remotely what have you i
think we've done pretty
pretty jolly well to be honest yeah
sandra you
um just a question on this photo um
well it looks great and you've got lots
of you know 150 k's worth of plants in
there
is this an example of retiring land
from from grazing and putting it into
native forest what is it actually
intended to deliver to the quality of
the
of the cedar stream which has um not so
much a sediment problem
but cooling nitrate problem so
what is this intended to achieve no just
go back
um one oh another one please
okay um obviously if you look
roughly where the the green patch is
which
um on the bottom left of the fields
a little bit further over and also for
that matter where the red circle is
that's
i suppose two degrees where the the
start of the silver stream is in that
area there and obviously
nitrates are an issue um that planting
well this whole piece here is actually
looked at has been
ultimately aimed as a 27 kilometer loop
trip that we're working with waimakariri
district council
and others on on creating a lot of that
i think roughly about two-thirds of it's
actually already connected we just need
to
connect it better together um that piece
of land became
the piece we were looking at and joel's
road up to the um
up to the right there that became
available and we took advantage of it
those
those plantings there probably won't
have a direct impact on the
nitrates in the water uh we were limited
in terms of the actual riparian planting
uh
because of the rivers uh needed to still
have access but effectively that
that track where they go through is what
will become the walking track
the other planting is actually more of a
shall we say a biodiversity game
for the area um and i know when jason
put that together he was looking at more
sort of creating a sort of more of a
forest or what he terms has been a
forest
kind of environment so it's not a direct
the objective was not to retire it from
farming it was actually just to put to
use that it
sort of more of an amenity value for
when the track goes through
and uh the loop
that kind of links it all together it's
about that areas about
roughly i think it's about a kilometer
long yeah
um can you also the whole project
um how far away because you've heard
that for a long
long time
district council to put together
basically a picture of what are the what
are the projects that are left
it involves traffic although a traffic
plan has been put together
um and then there's also there's an area
where we need to cross the last stream
um between the two reserves um there's
some some dot plan there there's a few
sort of issues there
um and then the other part so sorry to
answer the question directly how far are
we or what
way i'd suggest this is still would be a
good
probably five years away at least before
before it would become a reality that
would
would be doing pretty well for that it's
a combination of both you can see how
much those those two projects cost
and i know that my district council have
put other money in there as well
so it's um it's just going to be a kind
of a thing as we can afford it
um that we can put some money back into
this
um back into this catchment um
i would perhaps also suggest that at the
moment and again
if you want a strong signal through with
your action plans then you put that in
but there might be other priorities that
you may well put in there as well
we will need to have also some
discussions we need to be ahead with
some
with some landowners which can take time
hey thanks thank you that's really good
um just a couple of questions on the
last page
and the dropping sessions were for
farmers
um which are so advertised but i can't
remember the dates
um have they happened and how have they
been going how's it been going
um yes they are happening
okay and they're advertised in two
newspapers
so yes they are happening and they
continue to happen as well on a monthly
um well at this point
it just depends on on on the need of
what people are wanting in the community
i suppose but in terms of numbers yeah i
can't
i can't give you i mean what does
success look like in terms of
uh if i i think you're sort of seeing
about five
throughout that course on average um per
session here
i know i just saw the first advert i
thought sorry it read slightly oddly
about
you know that mean consent and i just
wondered if they were actually
attracting people and you know farmers
were coming to us
our land owners were coming to ask
questions but yeah they're working
yeah that's cool um so this and then the
second one is this um
econ staff working with railroad farmers
um to form a sub-catchment group
and i just wondered how that interacted
or intersected with the taranaki
sort of catchment catchment group or
land care group or whatever that sort of
caroline's been
promoting in that area
okay so um i think
um can i give you that offer i'm talking
you talk about actually rekahuri braided
river
shortly but i'll get to that point in a
roundabout way if you like
i'm sure you won't let me go there
judith yeah
thank you
um no if
looking back across the last six months
looking forward
um now i'm not gonna give a full update
on braided river revival on the actual
today there's a number of moving parts
um that are actually good moving parts
um that include just to touch on a few
things they include
um obviously the the
uh the lees valley through the woody
weed issue at the
top end of the river um the approach
will be
uh should be so um generic
um across the river but done on a reach
by reach basis we will then look at more
specific
issues that need to be um work with
they're already bubbling to the top
but if there's a task that i could
perhaps leave with the zone committee at
the moment is actually
with the the catchment group uh
down near waikoku the taranaki sort of
and those catchment-based discussions
we're having that area
and that really is if if you could give
us a strong indication of what you would
like
would like to see as far as aspirations
go for the catchment
and then we can actually fold those into
the
into the plan so that may be that you
want to see more water go down
down to taihara
it may be other options those sorts of
things but we'd appear to be looking for
that to come through from uh from the
zone committee
um over the next um sort of ideally sort
of month to six
six weeks um that would be would be
useful
just um back a little bit further to the
point about the um
i think it's probably a word that might
be being used about the catchment group
we're well aware that
it is actually the same thing has been
talked about it just might have been
some names and language
that have been used in there but we're
well aware that that group like all
catchment groups good ones are
from the uh the flex roots up and well
aware that that's what
is trying to be achieved at the moment
to um to get that to happen but it's
more i think that that particular point
in the
uh and the report was referring to um
the landowners that have been that um
marco and anna and
sapporo and i know dave's been if you
weren't aware that dave's been out there
as well
um he'd been working with perhaps even a
subset within
that area yeah okay
um so the other thing is we're actually
just um so part of also
river revolver we put in the report that
there's at least half a million dollars
being spent on the river we're still
awaiting an outcome
um and fingers crossed from the um
the infrastructure the covert fund so
we're hoping to come in the next
uh very soon we've been hoping for that
for a while
cheers any questions
yeah um yeah um so we were talking about
in our workshop before
i don't think you guys were in the
workshop we um just that there was a bit
of a lull in terms of feedback from the
taranaki string
farmers or mainly brian stokes and david
eder
but they had a drainage group meeting
and
david came back to me and said yes we
want to do it um
ring brian and make it happen sort of
thing and so i've been in touch with
brian
um he's i explained what we were doing
in the saltwater creek catchment and
suggested that we wait until
after we've had the meeting there the
community meeting
and then that could be the same approach
that we would take over there as well
and i've also talked to him about
broadening a taraniki stream group to
waikoku in little ashley because it
seems to be
a logical way to do it and i think
he was a wee bit concerned about himself
getting numbered with a lot of the
administration and not having the time
for it
and i've sort of said that well joe
buckner from land trust
landcare trust is keen to get involved
and between her and i
we could perhaps try and help get the
group up and running and then
possibly a funding was available for
coordinator after that
then he all his responsibility really
would be to
you know be fully supportive and help to
keep all the other farmers
supportive as well but just going back
to your um
request for the zone committee's
aspiration for
that catchment i kind of feel like the
community of that catchment are probably
in
a better place to give you feedback but
we need time to make that happen i don't
know what do you think
michael
recommendations they are there but again
we've moved on so i think
community involvement as well um
just to keep things moving forward but
while i've got the floor
and we're talking the taranaki marco um
i'd like to thank you for all the work
you did
with dave and anna on those farm visits
particularly identifying those critical
source areas
and starting to sort of put a plan in
place to to
rectify those that's um a huge milestone
and i think you need to take dave out
more often
i think it worthwhile thank you
just clarification these aspirations is
that for the
whole ashley rakahuli or just the
taranaki
in particular i was thinking of the the
catchment work that's been done down
there in the
modern term has now been there taranaki
um pepsi i know this might seem
uh still slightly a
wide sort of statement but even if it's
just an indicative
aspiration that we need further
discussion with
that would certainly be helpful at the
point that i'm making is it actually
if the funding comes through then some
of this work will go on to steroids
and therefore we need to know where it's
being aimed and we want to make sure
that
those things are actually within our um
within our target shall we say
yeah on the radar yeah
yeah when we come back we certainly
certainly will be
discussing the wider braided river
our revival with you yes
thank you gents
right so that was item three
um can i have a mover and seconded that
we
um acknowledge those reports please from
wdc
thank you
thank you very much right uh item four
we have um removed from the meeting and
we're going to reinsert it
in a month's time uh just to give us a
wee bit more time to clarify points
there
which brings us sprint to the floor
[Applause]
for item five committee updates
thank you michael um
just to go through the news they're
listed
in a reasonably regular sequence the
first one being planned change seven
um the major changes
regard um
the sentence around the evidence in
chief is exchanged from the 17th of july
expert caucusing will occur through the
month of august
with rebuttal evidence to be lodged by
18th of september so
obviously the hearings process is moving
on and uh
and starting to to firm up um at this
stage we still
don't have a confirmed time for the
hearing
but some probably by the time we meet
next month that may well be
added to the update so um i don't know
if anyone from the
e-canteen or with amber or anyone wants
to add anything in terms of
pc7 where it's at or whether just that
summary is
sufficient certainly the um
the zipper review of those six months
that we've just received would have
highlighted as you
saw that um you know that a lot of work
has gone in from the science team into
into the plane change into the into the
hearing process so
it's been a big piece of work over the
last six months for them
so if there's but questions on that
um communications uh
we've got what angus has provided
by way of probably the most topical
oysters one around courtney's stream
and he's included the responses there
from ekim
relative to those issues so we won't
read out in detail what you can
obviously read out but yeah
just because if there's any questions
related to those
communications items i think the only
other thing that we talked about in the
workshop
um with angus not being here is his
interest in working with the
subcommittee
in terms of engagement is something that
he felt was a very practical way for him
to
to line up and start to develop a future
strategy for cons and engagement
with the with the committee
so if there's no questions on that i can
i would be delighted to hand over to
carolina because the regime committee
which is the next item
has convinced carol has attended
a workshop and he's provided the
committee with a
success summary but you know yeah no so
um did anyone have any questions and the
next full meeting of the regional
committee is
next tuesday
all good okay um
what then follows is just some of the
action points from the previous
um from the previous meeting
so we're touching uh and i think we've
just
alluded to i guess looking at the
floodgates and updating
on the investigation into automating the
camera
floodgates so um i just know that that's
something that we would bring back to
our future really we're not this metal
um but um
yes i came with a floodgate automation
we wdc requested a
report from mahoney on the opponent of
the
katayaki and we have received that
report back which does oppose the
automation of the can river floodgate so
at this stage wdc is looking at taking a
report to our committee
the landlord committee to say that we
will not pursue this anymore
um as our council it was a
recommendation originally from the kai
appointment rehabilitation
working party which was just established
and uh
so it is a key asset and um obviously
you can might be
um have other thoughts but yeah that's
from wdc's point of view
well they may well be very consistent so
um you know that's great
sophie that's yeah i have
very good question caroline so uh
looking at the
eu management plan obviously fish
passage and you know the sporting were
the two
main reasons uh that they talked about
the policies there there is a
whole section of the analysis um so i
should i can offer to
you're about to see that i'm just
wondering why those things
were both not considered by the
investigation how did they fear the
investigation didn't
address them properly so what this
proposed was just to carry out this
feasibility study um and before even
committed funding to a feasibility study
we wanted to know
if the romano were opposed or ecan is an
acid owner because
either one would be a reason to not
pursue that it's been
it wasn't even just that given that um
feasibility
yeah it wasn't in the initial stage or
should we commit any funds to
um the conclusion so the the kaitiaki
sought
expert advice i'm not sure from which
expert but
they the advice they received was that
it would not
be supportive of the objectives in the
management plan
um the next item is around the
monitoring on the kaiapoi river
um and i uh boldly stepped into the
space of the science team with adrian
being away
because in the week we were preparing
these papers to think well a first step
and that would be to look at the larvae
site
so which is um increasingly being
positioned for monitoring data across
the whole country
to house and and you may recall from i
think the previous meeting if not the
one before
the groundwater team has recently
included
data on the lower side as well so
i could i was just looking to see
whether i could pull it up or whether
you'd have a chance to look through
make the money from data for the carpool
river that's on the lowest site
whether you'd like me to or whether you
just like to
look at it have a go oh see you guys
um i spend quite a lot of my life on
that side actually
and um well tim's here i thought i might
just highlight it
although it's slightly outside i was
under the waimakariri riverton
has 25 sites there but there's never any
data recorded
on stream health water health whether it
be
uh emp or e coli so
um that would be a big red flag to look
into please from my point of view
correct sorry so that's that
there's two there's three there's
there's the bridge bridge
but it's on the lava side there is three
or four sites here but
no data has been recorded um and we we
are asked quite frequently in this form
what's the level of opinions
good question what just to show you this
is this is
as is in the permitting papers
our right so having typed in kyboy
that takes you to
a range of sites that are actually
and then you can click on
the boat ramp which is a swimming this
is where we switch
this is where you swim let's have a look
can i swim here
current status
i think that's a do not swap
thank you sean got there
okay
so there you go it gives you this copy
areas
any of those in particular
so again that's i guess it's
highlighting what's recorded at that
site
says new zealand canterbury region water
quantity up yet
click in every region
and come down i should say river quality
yeah then he scrolled down
to waimakariri river it's right at the
bottom
on the left and that's just
missed all the quality sites
so then right come right down to the
bottom you'll see all the white mercury
river
yeah so we've got
we'll look at any one of those
approaches
a little bit
that one
yes
no deceased
so from here um with cam's guide so if i
click into just back into
you get to kind of see how it presents
information
nitrogen
just out of interest we've known the
nitrogens are in silverscript why is it
called
so high at half
there's nothing there's nothing around
at the top of it
because it's actually not stopped
but as you can see cola it's a very low
band away
electronics attracts people
management and as we discussed earlier
and
so if you mentioned i think we are very
close to having that
release but we don't have it yet so um
i mentioned by the time we get to the
next meeting in september we will have
uh it would have been released i don't
know if there's
um
with regards to the item 4.4 the
effluent discharge into the waimakariri
river um marco followed
up on that and has passed that on to the
christchurch west hamilton
monitoring team who will invented that
into their monitoring to keep track of
that
and falling from that we had a
an email from diane scholinde from the
city council
naming the discussion and interest
around the sticks
that was raised i think from from
michael's presentation as well at the
last meeting so
much like we've just done with looking
at the lava site um
diane sent through the links to the city
council's monitoring site which i've
included so
it's something else for the community
looking at the papers if they want to
have a look at
that monitoring data provided by the
city council that's the link
and those are the updates all right
there's any other questions
a stage questions
[Music]
happy okay um so we'll
make a recommendation that we receive
those updates from knowing
can i have a mover please
caroline followed by a second dog second
year that's all right can
you cool okay all those in favor
all right carol thank you
all right uh item six which is the
minutes from the previous meeting
um
so i'd like to move the motion that we
accept those missing for those minutes
which are held on the 6th of july
can i have a mover please dave ashby
second up
john thank you so take those as a
true and accurate record all those in
favor
all right carrie thank you any matters
arising from those minutes
sandra i'm just on page
i wasn't at that meeting but 31 on mine
uh
adrian um advised that he was unable to
retrieve data from the
loggers on the in the river and he would
update that at a later dates
i'm sorry i'm still not in position to
update it but we do we have had all this
uh this year
i should be able to do that in the next
week so we'll
okay thank you
um just item four which was about
coastal streams and there was
uh i think joe said there was going to
be a meeting sorry bottom left
page um page 33 there was going to be a
meeting with the new owners of pegasus
templeton group
about the state of the lake i just
wondered if on the 8th of july and i
just wondered if there was any report
back from that
update jared's gone anybody
oh thank you
i attended that meeting along with about
six or seven staff from waimakariri
district council
they were it was a very it was a very
productive meeting with it was really a
meet and greet with the new owners of
pegasus town
the templeton group and certainly the um
i can't even remember his name now i'm
so sorry but the
gentleman that um that was fronting the
templeton group was
came along and expressed very positively
that they wanted to
interact with both councils and with the
comm the uh
pegasus community group and do the right
thing type sort of thing
i was talking to um clearly
earlier today in this meeting and um
we're about to sort of push them for
what they're going to do this summer um
because we've
sort of had enough time now to sort of
assimilate
their knowledge of the lake they've
they've inherited
and do the right thing but by and large
i think it was a very positive meeting
for both the residents association and
both councils and our interactions with
the templeton group
who are the templeton group any ideas
um auckland-based um
property management portfolio group that
have sort of built
that have largely purchased almost all
of the sort of assets of the todd group
and um and then moving on there was
some media attention that they were
selling the commercial assets because
they're predominantly into management of
residential assets and things like that
so it's part of a much larger portfolio
that they've inherited the sort of
pegasus area but
once again they were very much looking
the community in the eye and saying yes
we know we've bought this lake as well
and we want it to be a good amenity and
things like that as well
well
around the um the community that um
that is a pollution event um i really
encourage them to
phone or tell other people to phone the
pollution hotline
the reason for that is actually we can
respond a lot quicker than things being
brought
here sometime later but also the item
actually gets locked
and therefore there's a process that
actually gets closed off so it doesn't
get closed off until there's a
conclusion
so it's a very efficient and effective
process i just um to
promote that you encourage the community
when talking to them if they are
raising those issues to find the
pollution online
thank you so that was advertised quite
frequently but i don't know if i've seen
it for a while
doesn't need a bit of a refresh in the
media possibly
all right when your budget's right yeah
all right
um need to slip in item
1.4 that i overlooked at the start which
is a registration of interest or any
changes to
if there's any notifications there as
good committee members you have to
acknowledge it at the moment
nothing i think which brings us to
item seven general business
um we were talking about it um last week
at the biodiversity working group
meeting but it's just in relation to the
race course quarry proposal that's been
in the
papers recently um
and just sort of thinking and sandra
gave us a very good rundown on where
it's at in terms of
um wdc and that it's at the very early
stages at the moment um is everyone
familiar with that
so just thinking it seems like on the
surface of it
um it's just a shall we quarry sharp
macquarie but
there's the matter of um the riverbed
nesting areas and the fact that it's
been identified that
they seem to do particularly well in
areas that have previously been quarried
and just wondering how the zone
committee can
provide some input or encourage other
people to sort of take up the course
perhaps the ashley rakihuru
river kia group in terms of promoting
the interests of the birds
and maintaining gravel extraction in the
river
yeah so i don't know if anyone's got any
suggestions
um i'll just follow up there was a nice
piece by
um the wdc mirror and the like rag which
sort of covered
over all those some of those points in
terms of it as a resource consent
application so
it's got to go through that due process
um
so all of us as individuals would be
perfectly able to submit on that but
from the zone committee's point of view
it probably
a non-starter has anyone had a
conversation with nick
litgard for example
so maybe which one of us should give him
a room
um just because i thought it was on the
agenda and it wasn't
um just to know that the biodiversity
i think you might call it a working
group not a subcommittee since we have
staff from myanmar district council and
econ along it
and we had a sort of a very informal
first meeting and a
slightly more formal second meeting last
friday
and so we arranged over a whole range of
topics um
but there's perhaps in future meetings
and they'll be slot on the agenda for
the
biodiversity working group to report
here
and there might be some you know
opportunities if anybody's got projects
or things i think we should talk about
um to get in touch okay quite happy for
you to
present that now if you like
um slightly one thing i think
wait till the next meeting thank you
okay any other general
away from the business earlier on and
we're finishing off the zipper
review of those six months just a really
high level
um bit of analysis which i think is
quite interesting
for everyone um
based on what was in this moving report
we had
uh 118 recommendations in the zip of the
way we've grouped them in the
reference document which very neatly
splits into 59
recommendations being statutory and 59
being
action focused and across that report we
had
47 recommendations out of 50 elections
which actually had
some sort of response to them which
means we include
the hearing uh 59 which are being
addressed through the plan change that
um so far to date that we've had 106 of
recommendations that had some form of
follow-up
so i think that's quite an interesting
over high level overview of
of how we're responding to the zipper
so so the twelve that have had no
response for that
whose will they don't know i think
yet you can assess that i didn't add
that into the obviously they're focused
on the other 106 but yeah
we can certainly do very miracle um but
yeah i thought it does actually show
a degree of response across the whole
range from both the district council and
environment canterbury but but yeah
let's identify the 12.
no thank you they're probably mine so
we'll park those
nothing else there ladies and gentlemen
mr ruben would you honor us please with
karakia to
point to me
uh apologies for lateness um
had a bullet inspection a guy turn up a
day early
bank managers ringing up two days late
and tim from conway laws jumping on your
cases
it yes we'll go this way thank you sir
so uh that concludes the meeting thank
you all for your
the attendance of september at 3 30.
thank you very much